foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
what's going on guys
I think you guys can hear me
I'm still a little sick
so you have to excuse me
just a little bit still a little under
the weather
I don't like the way this let's put that
right there
oh yeah that's right you gotta
there we go all right so here's the deal
with Pokemon
foreign
I have
gotten to the point in Pokemon
just like the very beginning
and this is as far as I gotten so we're
gonna be playing
let's see exactly what goes down
I don't know any of the stuff that's in
this Pokemon game I've never
played this game like it I don't really
know a lot of info on it either
yeah I I've always enjoyed the Pokemon
games Anthony it's just
I feel like they're running out of
ideals if that makes sense like they're
just doing anything they can't uh to
keep pop of them out they're not really
being efficient with them so as you can
see the only thing I got is I named
myself and I came downstairs and talked
to my mom
that's as far as I've gotten
and then I figured I'd go ahead and
pause the game at that point
do forgive the intrusion so you guys are
going to see me
read this is this is gonna be
interesting
[Music]
you are Master addict yes you know maybe
I shouldn't name myself addict I don't
like being called Master addict
that that's weird
on behalf of the Academy I must
apologize for the light arrival of your
enrollment documents and also for the
delay for my delay in introducing myself
moments where people like
the leaders of these schools and stuff
are coming individually these houses I
think that's a little bit unrealistic
he's got like Pokemon on his belt
I am the director of Naja Academy you
may call me Mr Clayville
but not at the campus yet the director
and you came in person to help my son
with his first date yeah Anthony what
makes sense that the director of a
school is going to come visit school
people individually
it uh so here at last the enrollment
documents this should have already been
delivered to you so they mess up and he
he's supposed to deliver them personally
at that point
a little bit fishy
so you come all this way and at least
you the only way I could feel like
he goes to people individually like this
like in a real life scenario if it's
like a really bougie school and there's
not a lot of people going and people are
paying like like 50 60 000 a semester
[Music]
I think he I think he got to think for
your moms that's what I think going on I
think he wanted to see your moms
he'd probably be like stalking her when
she goes in grocery shopping or
something because this don't seem right
this don't happen
why don't you head back to your room and
finish getting ready for school you'll
need your bag and your hat as well
you simply join me for oh oh now we see
oh that's what's going on they have like
some secret rendezvous thing going on
man look how look how extra your mom's
being there now Mr clavel you simply
must join me for a cup a this way
how can I reach such an offer
what are my brothers calling me
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
about that guys just look at you all
ready for your big first day it's
something about to do that that Spooks
me out
he's giving me weird vibes
okay I've officially don't care anything
about this conversation
what's the important thing but your
living room is hardly the place for it
would you care to follow me outside
what's he what's he you don't wanna
that's where he wants to ask you
something where your mom isn't present
I don't know
[Music]
what's going on
long loading screens that's what get
when you play the Nintendo switch long
loading screens and I heard the frame
rate's really bad in this game and
everything
right then dear time to come out oh so
you get to choose your Pokemon already
[Music]
I wonder what Pokemon I should put we
provide each suit with the Academy of
Pokemon of their own unless you choose
along these three you'd like to have as
your partner
the grass cat Pokemon spur
the fire Croc Pokemon crawl
and coaxley the duckling Pokemon hump
all right so who we picking
what's this so it turns out they're more
interested in you master act the
familiar with me
you could do co-op in this donataka
okay hold up I'll be at the house over
there just take your time and the Disney
can find me at once
now excuse me next until we meet again
what uh these three all look lovely but
you need to choose just one right not an
easy task
why not take this opportunity to walk
with these little ones and get to know
them I'm sure they have a lot to teach
you before you go did you guys see that
did you see that pop in
that was crazy
that was intense popping
[Music]
you you lying to McDonald's this game
don't have co-op
take it with you you're going on your
own
the rotten phone isn't there a Pokemon
called that
it's a brand new folk according to the
Sharks you choose uh okay we good
I got you
so they doing the
that's crazy it's got Co-op
oh this game runs horribly I can already
tell
look at me face through him
[Music]
they're really ghosts they're not really
Pokemon once if all Pokemon is just like
a bunch of
Pokemon's really like the main attack
this is having an LSD trip
or something like that that like no
Pokemon's real
they're they're just seeing things
that'd be crazy
they better run a patch yeah
Nintendo should be ashamed of themselves
look at these Pokemon just run
just kick one of them
do I have to talk to them
foreign
you don't want to get too close to that
water
I think this grass will whoop all day
yeah
oh now we can run
it didn't even let me choose it shows
for me oh that looks horrible man that
motion blur is crazy too
um
look man I'm not gonna
sugar coat it it don't run that good
[Music]
but at the same time we got to be real
this this system is probably not easy to
develop on because it's so weak
[Music]
man this is the closest thick Pokemon
will ever have and having a cutscene
foreign
ers
is that my rival
it's my arrival isn't it
has yet to make his choice you see
I do wonder which of this you choose as
a first Pokemon
burnt Apple
I mean I could use that apple he just
burned it Pokemon would be wasting food
man
I must say I wasn't expecting to see you
here quite so soon
hang on director is this who I think it
is
yes this is our Captain's new suit
Master addicts still not used to saying
Master eyes man he will be attending
as of today
so you're the kid who got moved up in
the road
I've been dying to find out more about
you
I'm uh not even trying to pronounce that
you guys know how I live in the school
dorms but home is here she a rich kid
she is spoiled brat I can already
confirm this look at the house she lives
in
and I'm pretty sure she's probably the
the dude the the person who's in charge
of the school's kid
because why why he there why he there
she is she's not his kid
that's actually kind of really weird if
they're not if if that's not his kid why
is he
at her house
answer this answer this Dawn is this
what you approve of
no I don't want to be friends with you
[Music]
in a clash ranked trainer in her own
right
a champion I absolutely love Pokemon but
in fact we should battle right now you
and me I knew he was going to do this is
gonna be my
right now you will be in the same class
you have plenty of time to battle later
[Music]
of course we'll be we're gonna be
neighbors and classmates or we'll be
able to battle as much as you want this
this she probably got all these Uber ass
Pokemon and she wanna battle me I feel
like
I feel like she's a bully
she's a bully she gotta be a bully
she got probably got six Pokemon on her
right now and she gonna beat me with one
Pokemon and then walk off
let me pick all this dial have you said
yes
uh which Pokemon guys hold up hold up
hold up hold up
I'm gonna regret this because there's
only 14 people in here I didn't think
that a lot of people show up for a
Pokemon stream
let's do a poll what
Pokemon
should addict
starts with
grass
water
and Fire
don't let me down Community don't let me
down
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so far water
oh oh 25 25 50.
oh oh here we go
I'm curious man I'm curious
I'll give you guys a couple more minutes
a couple more minutes to vote
not a whole lot more but a couple more
minutes
a couple more minutes
looks like grass is in the lead
what's going on guys
it looks like it looks like it's gonna
be grass
all right we're going with grass
let's get this grass Pokemon
it can use plant powers to soak up
whatever water uh
water you throw that's weird
yeah we're gonna go with them
nope
we don't nickname here we're not going
to nickname the starter but we will
probably nicknamed the rest
don't you love how they act like he can
carry like he's got the muscles to carry
that Pokemon on his shoulder like that
it won't it'd mostly be like this like
you're not holding I mean it might not
weigh that much but he's not he's scared
of bone
of course be ready to tuck safely inside
a Pokeball
I can't believe you actually
is weird
wow
so he's a chick
she is a champion and she has Pokemon
and Clay ball gonna just let her take
one of these starters
spoiled
straight up spoiled and of course she's
gonna
get my weakness
she probably gonna beat me
I'm about to lose
let's see
oh she chose my string that is right
um grass is more
what
when did they start doing that I thought
they've always
picked your weakness
it's been a long time so it's probably
why I'm getting them mixed up
foreign
Pokemon oops good call director I was
about to set up my usual Partners right
off the bat I guess I'll take this
chance to try my new buddy instead she
was about to bully us
well I mean we're not gonna have any
grass moves at the start so I highly
doubt we'll be able to just push through
her
[Music]
foreign versus
[Music]
I know this is your first Pokemon so
let's have some fun
oh we have a grass move
oh
hit her
hit with that grass move
oh that's horrible
[Music]
oh they did that to show you the
weaknesses
all right all right all right so this is
why they did it Anthony they wanted to
show you the weaknesses but they didn't
want to show it to you all the way
around imagine you
default lose the first battle
nothing nothing
[Music]
they definitely casualized the beginning
of Pokemon I remember when that first
battle used to be hard when you used to
have to like really take them to town to
beat that first battle
it was a lot about luck more than
anything
you winning your first final ever you
got even more power potential than I
thought you got to be a strong trainer
for sure but now I want to try a
different strategy let's go again just
one more battle
let's take a little bit too extra
let's battle against him you know you're
gonna have to battle her again
I'm sure you can learn a great deal from
a champion ranked trainer such as
yourself I don't wanna
I feel like
[Music]
it's kind of weird that they're making
your rival someone that's more
experienced than you and Pokemon
you have a smartphone let me see it for
a second
it doesn't just fly
[Music]
how
how is your rival gonna tell you about
the Pokedex
someone explained that to me how is your
rival going to explain to you about the
Pokedex
attic's gonna learn a lot under her oh
my God
look man get your mind out of the
gutters Matt
it's quite the age we live in now
filling out a polka dots by hand I can't
even imagine how much work that would
take
I suppose you can't
no matter how much Todd could change the
Wonder of meeting new Pokemon ever does
this is truly a Timeless pleasure
I don't know if there's supposed to be a
professor or not
I hope you both will work hard towards
the goal because I'm leaving your
pokedexes
it just feels weird having your rival be
a polka be part of the Pokedex
of course leave it to me
leave it to the beaver
little ones this time I were on our way
why can't I just take that one too
they should let me take that one too
[Music]
oh we're supposed to catch up wired
Pokemon now
foreign
press the minus button to open the
Pokedex okay
oh so this is cool they've updated the
Pokedex a lot
you're gonna walk with me if I'm gonna
exercise you get an exercise
there's a steep program
no I said you were getting an exercise
what's up Savage
addict I hear the number will be taking
you to school
that's right Mama leave it to me that
this girl is giving out some weird Vibes
right now
I had a small is hard and I read all
about the wonderful teachers you'll have
looked you'll have looking after you at
the school
it's kind of crazy that parents are open
to sending their kids randomly to a
school like this
because she just said she just read it
here's a bit of spending money to be
started off how much you giving me oh
she didn't give me no money she gave me
a sandwich
and five potions
[Music]
I thought she said she was gonna give me
money
she didn't give me no money all right
then you two better head off I suppose
take care on the way to school
the game gets fun once you get to the
open world
your mother's so nice at it
oh but I was going to teach you how to
catch a wild Pokemon come on
yeah she kind of she kind of played me I
could have swore it said she was giving
me money
[Music]
foreign
this game runs horrible man
they needed a new Switch
it's just point blank they need newer
equipment
all right here is poco path
all right so we already know this you
guys know this
she's going to teach you how to get
Pokemon we all know how this is gonna
get the Pokemon man the puppet's
horrible man it's horrible
is she gonna just give me one I'm gonna
need I need a little bit more than one
all right she gave me five I can work
with five I can't work with one
[Music]
I'm not catching that it's not happening
I'm not catching the pig
thank you
not catching a pig
we're fainting that pig we're not
catching a pig it's not happening
we're fainting that pit
think I catch a pig no it ain't
happening
knock that thing out
watch is gonna make me use a focal ball
knock it out
yeah we don't need a pig we good
next time try throwing a Pokeball when a
Pokemon's right on the tip of being
defeated you'll have a decent chance at
catching it then anyway here have some
more pokeballs just in case not every
catch works out
she gave me 15 pokeballs in all I
respect her
yeah we get it I've been playing Pokemon
for a very long time
I know how to catch Pokemon
let's meet up at that Lighthouse over
there
and see the school from the top
we ain't catch we ain't catching the pig
there's got to be better stuff to catch
than the big
there's another I don't want that either
whatever the hell that is
we don't want the pig either
is that a Pidgey
or whatever their flying type is
hold up
let's see what it is
it looks weird
I don't want that either we're going to
get rid of that too
oh yeah flying
I think flying's weak to
fighting type and
and uh lightning I think I don't know
whatever that is it's weak to me
Matt without fear
I don't have fear
told you that thing wasn't beating me
[Music]
but I'm gonna have to heal myself
that thing did a little bit more damage
than I originally anticipated it doing
where is it
I feel like we're going to catch one
Pokemon
just one
and it's not that Pokemon it's not gonna
be that Pokemon
we're just gonna catch one Pokemon
it's not gonna be that Pokemon either
look so weird what is that
what the hell is that
I'm behind you
oh I'm behind you
oh
what's this
I revived okay we might need that I'm
not catching a pig it's not happening
do you have to press a on these or do
you just automatically get them no you
do that
I uh
man where did these Pokemon come from
they're popping out of nowhere
I want something that looks cool
yeah these Pro controllers are pretty
good
I guess the pig won't have to work
all right we're gonna catch this Pokemon
guys we're gonna bite it
We're not gonna catch that Pokemon I did
it on it the whole time
I don't want none of the Pokemon here
I'm gonna be real with you guys
none of the Pokemon are appealing to me
hey actually getting a hang of how to
catch Pokemon okay
let me see so far what you've caught not
a damn thing
I've never heard the kind of cry before
could be some strong Pokemon or
something
I say we find whatever makes the cryless
is this where you see the legendary
because it kind of looks like the
legendary comes in the beginning of the
game a little bit
I'm still not
hold up we'll we'll address that later
whatever that sound is I don't want to
smoke right now
what's with these Pig Pokemon
I don't want them
why can't I have something that looks
cool
even remotely
can't be walking around here with pig
Pokemon and flower Pokemon
gotta keep it real man
is that like the Weedle the next Weedle
and you guys can have that
what is this
you know what let's catch this
I got a good feeling about this Pokemon
all right lightning Pokemon let's catch
it
[Music]
we're gonna try to catch it
two
three four
that's how you catch a Pokemon man see
when I want to catch one
it gets caught
you know they don't run from me they
want to work with me
they just want me to work for it
no we're not giving it a nickname
not yet
no okay okay
that's not entirely true Matt without
fear I played all the Pokemon games I
played sword and shield
uh I played um
all right so
all right so let's go over this a little
bit let's go with this
because now you're questioning
you questioning me man the reason I
brought up a first gen
is because that that's the only gin that
matters let's be real here
the only gen that matters
is that first gem okay so we're gonna go
over this all right
I don't remember the names
oh no no see Matt but you can say that
about yourself but you ain't saying it
about me I have played the other games
okay you know um
let's let's let's think of we'll we'll
go with the champions in every game and
and everyone in the chat you could
correct me if I'm wrong Brock had Rock
Pokemon Onyx and
um
and uh Geodude
bam sure he was the he is in the cantle
region so you know it is what it is
oh I see what you're saying Matt but we
still got to break this down you guys
can't question if I've played Pokemon
games or not it's not right
this should be illegal
oh you didn't expect me to know that did
you Anthony
did you
Misty she had a star star you and star
me
bam
how you like them apples
how you like that
grass green yeah Spencer obviously we
got to choose that grass you know I was
always uh
a Chikorita and Bulbasaur kind of person
see did you like what I just did there
Matt I referenced Gen 2 first
and and those how honed or
I always butcher names you guys know
this but they turned into a bigger
version of that
I could actually I wouldn't mind
catching that Pokemon
oh we fell
foreign
yo did that phone just break his ball
did that phone really just break his
fall
that was the most gimmick thing I have
ever seen the phone
made him hover in the air
foreign
oh his phone's a Pokemon
the mysterious Pokemon seems to be too
weak to move maybe you can give it
something to help perk up
I wonder if I give him this potion
all right do they want the revive
does he want my sandwich
they're gonna make me give this dude my
sandwich
[Applause]
look at that
he's he's very frustrated by that
sandwich
baloney it looks like some lettuce
[Music]
as far as he didn't eat your hand
nom nom
all it took was a sandwich to get him
back up and running
[Music]
what's in the cave
is he in the cave
[Music]
this must be like one of the most
generic
legendaries in existence to see it at
the beginning of the game
wow
what's he doing
is he using heat Flash
is that his evolved form
[Music]
[Music]
I know he didn't just evolve that must
be like
his battle form in the when he's on four
legs it's not his battle for him
something like that
we're gonna go in there and fight him I
feel like my grass type can totally
handle him
we're gonna beat him right now
come on man fight me
see you man appreciate it for coming by
let me fight you turn around
[Music]
now she's worried about me
[Music]
there's Vines everywhere I'm just gonna
climb my way up there
he gonna break the boat
oh those are there they are
oh he's trying to man he is totally
bullying right now
what is this
it's a weird looking Pokemon
I am in a um
a cave so I might want to watch out
being in a cave might run into a fire
Pokemon and just get clapped immediately
why is it
Play Why is it PlayStation me man don't
pan me out let me move oh a Diglett
did one for the rescue
we catching this For Old Times Sake
that's fine
we're catching this Diglett this Diglett
is ours Chad
we're catching this Diglett
we need that that Trio man
[Music]
I don't want a g i don't want zubats
Zubat can go somewhere else I'm not
interested in Zubat
all right
[Music]
here we go
I don't want to fight that thing the
thing looked kind of useless
I want this Pokeball over here
that's a bunch of them
yeah they they ain't so tough now are
they
[Music]
move
it's kind of pathetic this legendary is
pulling up in here on these little
Pokemon
and I think this Pokemon
you're almost taller than this Pokemon
like obviously he's like two of you but
he should be way bigger than you are
like you a little kid
I had to look up something's coming
what is coming
behind you
oh it's it's the evolved form
oh they making me fight it
level 40.
you can't switch Pokemon I don't want my
Pokemon game
man
ridiculous
legendary Pokemon done started something
[Music]
and I have to do it
[Music]
what is this
man there's a lot of them
there's a lot of them
foreign
[Music]
look man they can't even give you voice
acting they have Parts in the game where
it says up here quick and there's no
voice acting at all
which better this game would be with
voice acting
I don't understand why Nintendo
makes all this money and they don't
invest in a voice acting it makes zero
sense to me
thank you
I don't know it looks like
I'm gonna go back for that Pokemon
what you didn't tell what to do
I guess it's not like this Pokemon
trainer yet huh
[Music]
do you think this fellow is the one
making like mysterious cry before
she gets old man old man I look
why didn't you give me your number from
the start
don't you love how Nintendo didn't even
want to program them taking the phones
out they just programmed taking like the
phones flying out instead of like
animating arms coming out
my addict only knows how to pull
gotta get to the lighthouse man
[Music]
what happened
oh it's uh it's that um
that pig Pokemon we don't want nothing
to do with it though
it's because they have to animate the
throwing Pokeballs
who is this
our Pokemon looks like a giant dog
there's a professor professor Sada
this dude's a weirdo
the issue here is what in the world is
this Pokemon doing here and what is with
this form it's in
saved me from a tight spot
it's got like rainbow hair
I feel like a legendary Pokemon should
be able to beat level 40.
that's just my opinion on the matter
how does he know this Pokemon's name
sort of Pokemon that any old trainer can
help Japan it's special
special Pokemon is it
you think you're up to ordering kind of
around but how about I test your
wireless yeah sure let's let's battle
needless battle
I got this let's go
you're a challenge but look how weird
look at that chip bumped
all right so let's let's hit him with a
bite
there we go hit him again
we got three Pokemon
[Music]
he had one Pokemon
that's kind of pathetic
do you really think he was gonna win
that
oh attic that was awesome
I guess I wasn't even going to stand
using some Pokemon I only just caught
but if you really think you could take
[Music]
all right so this is weird this is a way
weirder story than I've ever seen
foreign
yeah my thoughts exactly where to
so he does have a Pokeball
somehow
[Music]
all right what we're gonna do guys
is imma eat and we'll talk games
I haven't ate today so you guys have to
excuse me
all right let me turn this down
oh
so out of curiosity
what you guys think's winning game of
the year
very curious to hear you guys opinion I
think I think Elder ring taking that
guys
[Music]
I'm Gonna Keep the mic away from me just
so you guys don't hear me chewing I
don't have a lot of food so don't worry
about it
foreign
[Music]
haven't they made a new Pokemon game
every year
for like the longest time at this point
foreign
[Music]
with X and Y the one before
um
the one before
sword and [ __ ] no the one before uh
let's go Pikachu and let's go easy
if I remember correctly
so there are a couple games I I am
missing
didn't they make two sun and moons
didn't they make starting to move one
and two
I didn't play those Sun and Moon
I played black and yellow uh black and
white
but I don't think I finished
foreign
game of the year
[Music]
foreign
because black and white
you had two additional Rivals if I
remember
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
one thing I will say is it's nice that
Pokemon seems to have its own like
it has a lot more emphasis on story than
previous
I really liked um Leon from uh sword and
shield
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I just didn't like the way it looked
it didn't seem to run pretty bad too
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the people in the community
I'm going to play them
fame's playing this game so I'm gonna
play Faith
foreign
[Music]
do some research tell me what starter
Pokemon mile started out with miles from
Windows Central
so we'll go snitch on them tell me what
he has
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
huh
[Music]
see you man
foreign
[Music]
foreign
oh there's the school
so that's the that's the direction we
came from
I like the school aspect they're giving
us
[Music]
[Music]
consider this the official town you
welcome to paudia
I guess that's the name of school
[Music]
[Music]
vamos come on
[Music]
we got this guys
[Music]
am I going the right way
no now I am
I don't want those
sure let's battle
what's he throwing out
it's a weird
spider looking Pokemon
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
most pokemon seem to only have one form
right now
I like how they're leveling everyone up
and not just one person I don't know
when they started doing that but I
really appreciate that
or a side duck
[Music]
there's another Psyduck back there
we're gonna get that one back there
[Music]
let's get this side up
I like how they show up on the field now
oh
come on
so what
I feel like he might kill me with one
more hit
all right he did another tell what so we
should be good I should be able to catch
him
[Music]
[Music]
see Spencer
register to sign up
[Music]
I like the new Pokedex
[Music]
more psyducks
we could definitely go for this Pokeball
over here though
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
this here is a Pokemon Center you can
come and catch a lot of things related
to your Pokemon but I'll leave the
explanation up to the pros here
I'd be in service well we already know
what this is they should let us skip
this if we know
you should be able to actively skip
these
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
pressing the R button is a quick way to
get
easy way to tell your lead Pokemon
[Music]
when you're Pokemon Angel happens is it
won't be able to explore on itself
[Music]
oh that's cool Auto battles that's
that's interesting
[Music]
oh yeah I think I heard something about
this you can make sure you can make uh
TMS down
you need lead points I Got 5 000 of
those I don't get so many of them
I like to help my Pokemon
foreign
did you know what
yeah I knew all that
welcome to the Pokemon mark
so they they kind of like Main Line
mainstream
all of the Pokemon centers down
it used to be like individual
buildings it doesn't look like it's
going to be individual buildings anymore
well that's not necessarily a bad thing
but it's interesting how they're doing
it
man how you gonna do me that way Matt
without fear
foreign
[Music]
guys
nice little town
it's like three buildings
there's that Pokemon I keep avoiding
better than the me
what Pokemon's in this area
[Music]
what is that
let me snatch this
oh yeah I remember that the rare candy
levels
foreign
[Music]
out
I wonder if
so they they do they don't even
disappear
that's interesting
it's a level six too
foreign
attack him
[Music]
you can attack him go
oh
[Music]
what's Marvel's snap
foreign
take him out
there we go
go go
do all the work
keep going
we want all the work
knock them all out
you can do it
knock him out
knock him out we we look in the end
everything man it's my Pokemon versus
the world right now
but look at this little guy go
he's taking everybody out you can get
some you can get some you all can get
some
oh I love it
well I'm not even doing nothing I think
you could theoretically like go
like go eat and come back to like a
couple levels higher
I'll have to try it I used to like the
Marvel
Ultimate Alliance I don't know if it was
called Ultra Delight but there used to
be a Marvel game that was turn based
that was on Facebook that I actually
paid money and stuff and everything
you can do it
knock them out
foreign
we're going back
there's too many people we ain't knocked
out yet
knock them out
[Music]
go
go
[Music]
get that Jigglypuff want to be
get this one too
don't let him reach me
don't let him reach me man
go
get him
no don't the other two don't let the get
away I don't care if he's flying get him
get him
[Music]
get him
there's one right here too
get him
oh
oh
over here get this yellow one
foreign
by this
[Music]
they're gonna like DME a threat first
[Music]
let me get your snap code how do I even
find that thing
like to be honest with you I don't even
know if I have
the um
the online for Pokemon
I mean for Nintendo I don't think I have
it anymore I think I got rid of it
though you have to have their
subscription service to play games
online
come on
all right I think we've done
[Music]
foreign
I feel like
the auto battles is just wonderful I'm
not gonna lie
the auto battles is wonderful
look how old this dude looks
he's got like Perfect Teeth though
[Music]
yeah sorry about that dog
once uh my finances come up a little bit
uh you know I'll I'll get the online we
can play it
right now I'm still looking for a job
but aren't switch codes switch friend
codes free uh the codes are free what
you feel free to any of you guys can add
me it's the
it's the online that's not free like you
have to in order to play it with people
it's just like the other stuff man in
order to play with the other people you
have to do it
knock them all out
oh never mind
oh we gotta get it
foreign
for the culture we need a Pikachu
oh it confused me
let's just scratch him
level eight two I like that
how do I join the family plan
you know I used to be on a cousin's
family plan
and uh he got upset with me once because
I had to call him to work
and he took me off that snap took me off
it man
you know we family he took me off over
calling her to work such a say
[Music]
we got the Pichu man
it's an unskilled and snoring electric
uh electric power any kind of shock
causes it discharge uh energy
spontaneously
I wonder
I wonder when you can
how what level do you have to be Donna
talking for Pichu to evolve hold on let
me Google it real quick
because if it's not like absurd
get us a Pichu real quick
oh it evolves off some off of your
friendship
I ain't trying to make I ain't trying to
oh that's that's
I mean I guess
[Music]
where's the friendship
how do I see if this thing likes me or
not
I know it probably doesn't
check markings no
how do I see if it likes me or not
is there a stat somewhere
[Music]
foreign I like the the new way that the
Pokedex has ran
I think it's really uh convenient the
new way the Pokedex is ran
so it looks like if you catch them
they have like special things here
that's cool
[Music]
so that's a regular Pikachu
foreign
I like the recent notes I like that
all right let's change
[Music]
all right uh send me uh an email
um
let me see if I can
I didn't want to do that
I want to level up this Pichu
that's what I want
get him he's right here
foreign
one thing
here fight these birds
they're weak to you fight these birds
Peach you listen to me fight these birds
fight the birds
[Music]
fight the birds
all right if you run because you hurt
I'm gonna heal you
now fight the birds Pichu
[Music]
you can't win anything
at all
[Music]
fight this one
finally
we see some some progress with Pichu
have you run to any bugs yet not really
foreign
[Music]
look how bad that rock looks
that rock looks horrible
I don't want peach you out Pikachu just
getting wrecked
is this a Talon
no it's a swallow isn't it
oh don't even have electric moves that's
why
we've got Thunderstruck so I guess it
does
[Music]
hit him hit him
you'll go first next because the light
oh quick attack
you can do it
that's right
oh this thing is uh it's a bad matchup
I'm not fighting this
[Music]
but I do want it
hold up
oh this thing's ballsy too it comes
straight at you
water gun that thing
do you mind
[Music]
Pokemon seem to be a lot easier to catch
in this game
foreign
[Music]
magical leaf
I think it's safe to get rid of tell
what for right now
[Music]
[Music]
no we're not naming it
you know what
[Music]
there's another one over there
I'm kind of curious when this thing
evolves I need to look it up
all right I don't need to really do much
more
I'm gonna see when this thing evolves
when does what was the of wolf
[Music]
[Music]
okay hold up
what level does he evolve
what level
the
16.
all right chat
he evolves at level 16.
80 performance issues yes there's a lot
of performance issues
all right he evolves at 16. I kind of
want him to evolve real quick
foreign
we're going to evolve this thing
I Believe in Us evolving it
[Music]
I don't think it's gonna flop I do think
it's gonna sell well but I'm hoping
that the way this game runs is going to
show Nintendo that you neither a need to
optimize these gains better you need new
platform I do think they need a new
platform uh I don't think
too much like it's going to really
matter they need a new platform in China
[Music]
there you go
get rid of them
don't let these Pokemon fool you
get the pig one go get the pig Pokemon
[Music]
there you guys one over here too
come on
hit him there you go
you're doing right by me man you're
doing right by me
[Music]
do you think it's gonna be called The
Switch too
kind of curious if you guys think it's
actually being called The Switch too
thank you
they definitely need new hardware
yeah I'm not saying some games won't run
better but I'm saying logistically like
right now they probably need more new
hardware than anything else
I feel like if they want to make Pokemon
games like this and evolve this type of
formula that they're making with Pokemon
they're gonna need more uh
better Hardware
ah almost almost touched the pig hit him
he's right here
don't be scared of him
he's after me being the Pokemon I I
raised you to be that's the wrong one
I want you to hit this one
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I think it's a a lot of factors I don't
think it's just one or two things I
think it's a lot of factors
uh they could definitely make the game
better while no one's denying that I
think everyone can agree on that
thank you
I don't care who you attacking just give
me some head some HP
I like how they kind of have the XB
share on everyone now they don't get the
full thing but they do get leveled up
[Music]
um
[Music]
what's this XP yeah
foreign
[Music]
I they better not call it the Wii U
that's what you
[Music]
but see I I don't believe
and correct me if I'm wrong Dawn the
taco I don't believe that
they own the Pokemon license
I think they just agree to publish it
they have like a really good
relationship with them but I don't think
they own it
attack him
he's right here
I mean I can knock them out
let's see if we get more than 21.
this alarming voice
[Music]
this thing's really slow
[Music]
so you did got double
I don't think it's worth it though
because the amount of time it took me to
beat them I could have probably took out
two Pokemon
yeah it's definitely easier to level up
by just
having them take out these Pokemon
because especially if you get them like
real close together
they'll take out three or four Pokemon
like like quick quick
[Music]
I think he's
all right so it's not every Pokemon
[Music]
I'll read that in a second dog
[Music]
let me ask you guys a question
if I streamed on Twitch would some of
you come and watch that on Twitch
because we have an IOP twitch channel
that we do nothing with and I feel like
we need to take the initiative to uh try
to grow that a little bit
because obviously I'd like to to do the
podcast stuff as long as possible and
you know making
increasing our Revenue off in multiple
areas could definitely help with that so
if me streaming on Twitch can help
sustain us more long term I'm I'm open
to trying it
and plus I think the the Fidelity of
twitch it actually looks better in a lot
of ways
look at this pig
stop going back in your Pokeball
I can give you permission
[Music]
I want to be the very best but you're
gonna have to be the best first
[Music]
yeah the problem with YouTube is
I don't want to like
constantly over
do the subscriber face because we do
want to like eventually gravitate a
little bit into shorts and I don't like
the way shorts look on YouTube
I think it's like very
takes up a lot of the screen
foreign
I don't watch Twitch either I don't but
I do feel like that is an Avenue that
can really help us because where there's
so many people that's that isn't on
YouTube that have that same mentality of
watching twitch all the time I feel like
we could really grow by streaming on
Twitch and getting some of those people
to watch the podcast
now I'm not dumb I don't think every
person that watches me on Twitch is
gonna watch the uh the Poke uh gonna
watch the YouTube channel and watch long
form content like like uh like podcasts
but I do feel like we could
you know increase our reach by
increasing twitch audience
[Music]
I'm pretty much the only thing I do
shorts with is tick tock
uh we do have a tick tock so you guys
could definitely follow it if you guys
want to but that's the only thing I do
tick tock
okay
[Music]
if y'all upload a YouTube later I'm
definitely check out the YouTube video
later though Oh you mean like
like a video like this check it out on
YouTube later
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hold up give me a second guys
[Music]
[Music]
I'm uh
responding to cogging them in the in our
chat
[Music]
I just realized something
I'm gonna have to go real quick
and retweet that because that last tweet
doesn't lead to anything unfortunately
huh
I can't remember
the
the dimensions on the on the stream was
wrong
and for some reason
it wouldn't let me switch it
so let me
let me switch these
let me delete this old one real quick
feel free to uh go on and tell people
that I'm live if you guys want to
make these little live streams a little
bit bigger
[Music]
all right there we go
there we go
let me get the one that we're doing
right now
[Music]
all right there we go
[Music]
[Music]
all right there we go
uh let me play with your joystick look
at him in there man tell solve I said hi
uh solve
look man
I'm still convinced you saw his wife
[Music]
oh they want to battle me now
I caught a lot of Pokemon and I leveled
up a good amount I don't think this is
going to end the way she wants it to
foreign
you are challenged by Pokemon trainer
and emio for whatever her name is
[Music]
all right so it's time to switch this
[Music]
oh we're doing two V2s
oh she had she's gonna use another
Pokemon okay
[Music]
all my Pokemon are stronger than there's
level wise
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
didn't work out the way she thought it
was going to work out
[Music]
now we're gonna stay in
[Music]
oh look at that
[Music]
let's just throw another one at him
[Music]
oh what oh she's doing that crystallized
thing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we will magic leap this chick up
[Music]
it didn't do nothing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm paralyzed now
that could be annoying
let's just try to get this attack there
it's a bad matchup they could you
literally do that five or six times
I don't like their gimmicks I I didn't
mind mega evolving I thought that was
interesting but I don't I didn't like
the Giga thing for sword and shield and
I don't so far I don't like this
crystallization thing I do like how it
can change the element of the Pokemon I
feel like that could really lead into
the PVP aspect of Pokemon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
540 for beating someone in a Pokeball
game
oh she can't be revised acting like I
lost the Pokemon fighting her
foreign
there's a ton of hills and stairs and
stuff in the city so I'm going to take a
quick breather and then catch up with
you
oh I didn't you're right it probably is
set in the end
foreign
[Music]
the motion blurs
has given me a headache this kind of
looks like the last City in sword and
chill
[Music]
not the biggest city foreign
[Music]
lots of folks here come
[Music]
see I got the case too guys I got the
case too
uh tasty food
I was speaking of battling I want to
make sure you're a good Tesla's perform
at the too bad
there's a fuse the guy to do before that
happened but I'll take care of him
know why you just have fun looking
around the city for a bit
there's so much to do grab a bite buy
some accessory just pass up a uniform if
you want personal recommendations you
got to see the deli recent stay so handy
items for your Pokemon
probably stuff you uh they hold for
battles
[Music]
I do like the aspect that you're in like
school I don't think they've ever done
that like this is a huge step
in a different direction for Pokemon
that you normally get
I like this
probably can't have Pokemon battles in
the middle of town like this
[Music]
foreign
look at that Poppin
[Music]
wow
look at that
that's crazy
Nintendo should be ashamed of themselves
[Music]
look at how he walks up these stairs
foreign
whatever the dude name is for my hero
dude that does the ice abilities
we got a quota we're supposed to fill
for new members just sign up already
I'd rather not help her out
here's the thing though donotaku
the game's out for the switch so I got a
blame switch
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I watch my hero
[Music]
I'm I'm caught up on the new uh season
too
it's physical defense is too high
what level is that thing hey I did go a
little bit too over foreign
thank you
[Music]
I love it
what's blocked dude
um I'm watching sub because that's the
only because I don't want to wait
because dubbed you have to wait a little
bit couple weeks and I'm not waiting a
couple weeks
I feel like this is an important move
block
I don't know dog should I keep block
inform me Dawn
should I keep
block
one second
[Music]
[Music]
my bad Cog was calling me
[Music]
um
dub is two weeks back
I just I just can't wait I prefer the
English dubbed because I'm used to the
the voices but I don't mind watching it
and subbed
so I don't need I don't need block okay
[Music]
foreign nobody like you good at battling
anyways
[Music]
I can't believe you added you don't have
to go find Ramos but you'll have all the
bad as you need of me
um I watched all of the last uh this the
part two of uh Attack on Titan I watched
it
[Music]
well it's the crystallization thing
I ain't really trying to make
crystallization for Pokemon though I'm
sure I'm gonna have to
for the game but I don't like the whole
car I don't like the mechanic
I'm probably gonna
I was gonna get to the first
don't you love how they how they're
scared of her
everyone is so scared of this chick but
I beat her multiple times
maybe it's because she's not using her
true power on me
this isn't her final
[Music]
this isn't her final pal her final
that's what I'm looking for
this isn't her final form
that was a mean Mouse
all right we're crystallizing
[Music]
yeah Crystal likes him
we're gonna make a rock throw Of
crystallization
[Music]
I like the the music though
these are pretty good
foreign
pretty simple
[Music]
your Pokemon Bronze so bright
and I got another five dollars so I've
made like 15 dollars
in this real game playing uh against
these people
sometimes you find a Pokemon with Terror
type it's totally different from his
usual type that
difference can open up strategic options
got a charger for the Pokemon Center
after every use by handling your team
though all right so that's fair I
suppose
[Music]
I love what we're just not doing
anything with them we're just let them
leave
[Music]
excuse me
he looks just like Torah man I don't
know how to pronounce it but he looks
just like him
that's someone on the art team got to be
a fan of my hero
they gotta be
I don't think I've seen a girl I don't
think I've seen that girl right here
maybe she's new
bag though loved that fluff yeah that
was definitely an easy bag
anyway seems like the trouble is tied
down so we better get the book and climb
up uh get ready to climb the worst
stairs in the world I don't know the
stairs and sky are going up to the
graveyards is pretty bad I think it's
definitely worse than these stairs
[Music]
foreign
up here
wasn't too bad climbing the stairs
the Psyduck
[Music]
I don't even know what that Pokemon is
look how
look at this
look how bad
this is
that walk is so glitchy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this psyduck's everywhere
this this place is huge
Master addicts
it's weird he calls me master
[Music]
foreign
Academy
not that I was expecting any less our
champion or extreme president
reliable as ever
she's a
she's like one of those teachers pet
that does whatever she can to uh be his
classic as possible he's useful as
possible
well I don't know how to look at my
friends right at it
but speaking of which we saw some of the
team skid kit uh Team star kids and town
director you did where
it was down the stairs for the gates
they're harassing this kid with an EV
backpack
that is quite news are they still to be
found out there
actually attic flexed on him and ran him
off
you don't say
of course it's fine of course let's find
things to help try to follow uh of
course it's a fine thing to try to help
a fellow student Master at it
but you might wish to show a bit of
restraint as you find your feet here at
our Academy and Miss Minard do remember
that the school staff is here to resolve
any such problems they weren't there
oh yes yes sir director oh right yes sir
director a child with the Navy back back
you say I suppose that might be Miss
penny
I've lived here she's come to class at
least oh and Miss Miller whatever her
name is if you if you'll be so good do
report Mr Jack is about the team star
business
as your Homebrew teacher he he should be
kept
I pray appraised on all such growing
things
got it soon oh look at the time you two
better hurry off to class because it's
going to be starting soon we're in class
1a at it come on I'll show you this way
at least I don't have to go to class 1A
she gonna take me there
[Music]
look how bad that look look at the
facial like
it's crazy guys
[Music]
look how bad the frame rate is on this
screen
we have some exciting news this morning
who wants to hear it oh I want to hear
the news the exciting new news is I'm
here as a new student
yeah we have a little life for enjoying
our half these home room is today
whisper whisper whisper
I wonder what they'd be like
all right you can come down in
could I trouble you for a few roads
introducing yourself that the frame rate
on this game is ridiculous
it's ridiculous look at this
how did
Nintendo
and
freak Game Freak see the performance in
this game
and said this is good let's send it out
[Music]
I wonder if they would buy their own
game on the real I wonder if Nintendo
executives
and Game Freak Executives would buy
their own game with the issues that this
game has
[Music]
[Music]
what's your favorite thing about Pokemon
[Music]
I like everything about Pokemon
it had to run good though Dawn
you want all the trouble right here it's
a spill addict
what do you have to get you must have
some kind of dream right
I want to I want to be a strong trainer
I feel like
she's gonna respect that I want to be a
strong trainer she seems to be in that
same boat
you will be oh I just know you and me
were going to get so strong battling
together well thank you for telling us a
bit about yourself addict I'm Mr jocks a
tech biology here at the Academy and I'm
also your homeroom teacher
foreign
but see here's the thing
sword and shield didn't try to do
anything like this
they they changed the formula up a
little bit for soldiers Shield but it
wasn't like this
[Music]
[Music]
I ain't trying to
[Music]
a battle class
[Music]
come out
they have to have anything up by then
[Music]
see and that that's fine hold on let me
[Music]
let me turn down the capture card pretty
good for a second
that's okay
if they have to refurbish stuff but it's
like to me they're they're clearly gonna
right now they just did Pearl and
Diamond obviously they're going to
continue that spiral probably re make
anything else I actually would like them
to go remake the original again because
I felt like let's go Pikachu and let's
go
um
let's go Pikachu and let's go Eevee want
your standard Pokemon games and I think
it was unfair to give us that title at
that point and call it the remake of
that gin
I would like to see another Johto that'd
be cool too Pokemon games kind of like
sports games they can only do so much
yeah but I feel like
I feel like this game runs like horrible
this game was horrible this is enough
difference
to make me consider Pokemon has changed
a little bit is it really look I gotta
talk to you guys man
we gotta talk
Is this different in its entirety no
but I do feel like this is different
enough to make it seem like the Pokemon
formula has been freshened up a little
bit
yeah see that that's my point like let's
go Pikachu and let's go Eevee I feel
like didn't represent
the first gen Pokemon I want a sword and
shield
like Kanto region
you know I want one with silver and gold
you know Ruby and Sapphire I think they
just got theirs
I think they got theirs last year or
something like that
um
I think the only way you can like do
anything drastic with Pokemon is is to
make it
make it a little bit more dark maybe I
don't know because like they do keep
trying to change things up with like the
crystallization stuff and so I can't say
they're not trying nothing to change out
the formula of this game
Auto Battle Is Good
how did you ever send me a message on a
Twitter
no you didn't
that's fine though
all right
I really liked what I played a black and
white if they re-back re-did black and
white I would play it again
I didn't like the online features of
sword and shield though
I didn't like let's go I thought they
were cool but there was no battling in
let's go really so that's the part that
irritated me the most no like free roam
battling
I didn't like that
I don't like the throwing thing you you
know
the Auto Battle is this really good
feature really good convenient thing and
I think that it did Justice here I do
think it did Justice here
all right let me switch back
foreign
they said there's a battle class
available where's the battle class
[Music]
let's go to the stuff
[Music]
here tweet me doll
I could have swore I followed you
I don't know there's so many people
that's always following me it's hard to
keep up with everyone
I'll keep Twitter up though just tell me
whatever you sent the Tweet out I'll
follow you
foreign
this isn't an old Pokemon
I'm not hungry
I'm here to battle when I eat
[Music]
I'm here to battle naughty
here's the staff probably some gym
leaders or something here
she looks like a gym leader
no
tweet me
so I can find your account because
uh is your account exactly how it is
spelled here
[Music]
yeah see I look up Donna taku there's
like a bunch of Donald talkers
and none of them are following me so
it's clearly the wrong one
[Music]
all right
very well Champion I trust you to handle
this in my Steve so who's that it seemed
like a very prominent character
foreign
[Music]
like a very prominent character
she got like that hair that you just
don't mess with man
[Music]
you guys see that
[Music]
that's definitely
nowhere near your name there buddy
[Music]
that's definitely not nowhere near your
name that's a burner account
[Music]
what you doing with that burner cow Dawn
what you doing with that
[Music]
I hope they fight I I like the
the story orientation now Pokemon's
always had a story but I've always felt
like sometimes it's weak
I don't feel like this year so far as
weak
[Music]
this is like more of like a clout
chasing Pokemon game
foreign
[Music]
you could take on the
the gems is any order you want so I'm
kind of curious how they balance that
I my your burner accounts see secret
with me the name is Secret with me
the last one started another long ago
after the beginning of the school
[Music]
I don't know yet to say I've been
looking for
I wonder if there's anything after
champion
like I wonder if like the Elite Four or
anything or come from this school or
something I'm curious on like the lore
of their ability with this new region
let me go ahead and save gem locations
in your map access and you can go from
there
foreign
the Pokemon gym locations have been
added to your map map app
Victory Road
[Music]
give it some thought
what was that sound did you guys hear
that
[Music]
oh it's a dog or a Pokemon of some sort
where's it coming from
[Music]
I know you guys had to have heard that
it was pretty hardcore
[Music]
they said there was another battle
how do you start the class
oh look it's a Gengar
[Music]
got it with the cafeteria next
that was a weird school bell
[Music]
[Music]
hope your students are going okay so I
guess you do have to pick out some form
of food
let's get this fire alarm one
let's get the cheapest the cheapest one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm confused there was it like splitting
it up with everyone
oh no
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one second guys
thank you
[Music]
jeez
[Music]
all right so
I'm officially part of Don utaku's
family list so how do I get you in here
I assume you need that
oh okay okay
but when you play on Twitch okay
but here's for everyone in here that's
my um
that's my thing
oh hold up hold up you guys can't even
see it all
there you go
foreign
so here's the games I've played you got
that Pokemon Sword 120 hours
Scarlett played a little while
you got the Mario and rabbits 15 hours
live alive 25 hours
see this is this is how you know I
actually beat the games that I review on
the channel
Mario rabbits Sparkle hopes I just
reviewed that 30 plus hours I didn't
really play a whole lot of brilliant
Diamond I have it I just haven't really
played a whole lot of it
um I'm interested in in Monster Hunter
stories too but I seen it's on Steam so
I might try to go that direction later
triangle strategy I played a hundred
hours of triangle strategy I really
enjoyed that game I think you guys
should definitely try it out if you like
bravery default 2 play 30 plus hours I
didn't really play the Mario thing
uh Mario Kart Eight I played a hundred
and ten hours of Mario Kart 8 and Mario
part Superstar Superstars I usually play
that at my friend's house I don't
actually play that myself
Zelda Skyward Sword HD you remember uh
me and King had that little bickery
thing with that put in 40 hours in that
game I actually enjoyed that I can't I
can't tell you guys here I actually
enjoyed Skyward Sword regardless how the
motion sisters thing is is ridiculous
and I'm still holding on to that I do
think it's a little bit better uh if you
if they made it a traditional Zelda game
it would have been a good Zelda game
foreign
must be this dude back here he's the
only one that stands out
oh it's that dude
[Music]
[Music]
man I hope girls is is important people
like her
cool
[Music]
you got to help me with so I can finally
make a dream a reality what's the Dream
First
aha caught your eyes you want to hear
about my fight right
this might as comes up but in fact I'm
all about that picnic Life The Great
Outdoors the perfectly prepared sandwich
of all time I'd put a little extra in
there
not half bad at cookie either I could
tell you all right Donna taco
you know how I feel about
about um
Skyward Sword you're trying to bait me
that's what you're doing you're trying
to bait me
and you know what it's gonna work
I think I'm gonna make a video on my
personal YouTube channel of why
breath of the Wild
missed the mark for me and I think I'm
gonna have to like like
I'll have to wait for the next Zelda to
get announced like the actual release
date with like a lot of info so I can
make a a video that's like kind of like
worded on stuff that I would want that
one to be remedied from the from breath
of the wild I didn't like
[Music]
foreign
even know
I didn't even know Nintendo was still
doing the the family plan thing
I thought they would have just dropped
that by now
I beat breath of the wild I still think
it's a good game it's just not a good
Zelda game
[Music]
I mean I'm gonna have to help you it's
not like it's gonna let me not help you
[Music]
it's Celebi on his phone
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is it your mom or the chick oh we don't
know
my name is Sophia but never mind it said
I'll talk to you about I hear your
travel series potential in that
description is accurate there's
something I'd like to ask of you tell me
addict you know about the team Star
right yes
foreign
man I'll see you
t-shirt is a group of trouble
of troublemakers formed by some Academy
students a while back they cause
headaches to school and try to bring
other students down to their level and
every survived only let them get away
with it
so I come with a plan to bring down team
star and force them to disband for good
I call it operation star Phil Starfall
but I need allies to carry this
operation I'd like you to be one of them
sure
this is not gonna let me not do it nor
do you replying out of the second we can
discuss it each other at a time
a lot of talking
please do a treat people if you're
making calls it's in school don't you
of course sir
you don't want anyone that's overhearing
any personal information after all
honestly there are so many things we
need to be careful about in these days
and age on you go then young man
oh I'm going
I'm going
team Starry you see
[Music]
they could change the music every now
and then I know they will you know we're
still pretty relatively
soon in the game
calling Master to the to the director's
office please
once again Master Eric to the director's
office
did I just see that dude
how do you get to the director's office
I assume it's at the top floor
[Music]
[Music]
dude's wasted my time man
thank you for coming Master addict have
you been enjoying your time here at
nargen Academy
no I haven't
I see you remember always here to lend
an ear should you find you're struggling
anyway
now you'll be wondering to me and I have
simply conversed earlier in the
cafeteria let me show you there's a
reason I've asked you to be here in the
my office
it seems that a friend of mine has a
serious matter of that we'd like to
discuss with you
foreign
[Music]
oh it's on the TV
it's probably the professor
I don't know how Co-op Works in this
game
yep professor
as a snows Arrow zero oh that's where
the the uh
is it in the crater or is that the
building beside it
you're ridiculous man
I like the sound man
I did not mean to offend you in fact I
wish to ask for your assistance
and then
how good is he that your world has been
quite a while since we last met
ERS once in my care you see
it's pokeballs originally mine
I assume you received it from a young
man that's her son
I mean obviously I got no choice
I love how they give you like the option
but they know they're not going to give
you real real options
foreign
could this Pokemon have its Origins with
Ariel zero
what did he do
they're very cryptic on this game
they don't really tell you much of
anything
[Music]
I get it go see the professor
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
in the school dorms your very own
private roommatic let's go check it out
maybe I don't want to check it out this
chick I feel like she wants something
very aggressive let's go let's go to
your room
what's going on in your room your room
all to yourself
actually this is new to me as it is
you'd ever been here before
it's and obviously the bed's the first
thing to look at this game is crazy man
[Music]
I see you tomorrow when you're rested up
then we can battle even more take care
she's a very aggressive person
[Music]
sure
the days quickly Fall by after you start
your new life
oh so
okay so it's like skipping a bunch of
time
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
what's the time for
probably ending it there man
[Music]
so far so good
the girl's getting off in like 30
minutes someone
get some stuff done before she gets home
but I'll talk to you guys later
appreciate it for coming out